so what did you mean I saw that you
recently said you thought the world had
retired you well I think you know it
this is not a business that is
particularly kind to aging yeah and I
was blowing along just doing one show
after the other for a long time and then
all of a sudden I just kind of couldn't
get arrested and a lot of women more
than men yeah well yeah yeah yeah yeah I
I do get upset though cuz I I feel like
men like they get the salty gray-haired
look and it's like Oh sexy and then
women and it's like mmm not so much it
didn't work as well but I went gray for
a while I was like I'm not dying my hair
anymore I'm not gonna do it but I
actually love you gray in the show but
you know I got a lot of blowback it was
like really
you wanted this really yes I did oh but
your name is meemaw like I know but
that's a wig yeah I love it it's very
Emmylou as well Harris yeah I just
listen to her new album today I love you
and unbelievable unbelievable I can't
even believe I've heard her live I feel
like coolest but let's talk ghostbusters
as well so what's the new film how's it
going is it good it well it's I haven't
seen anything yet but we have completed
it and I think it's gonna be pretty
I'm excited fabulous I mean I don't know
you have a problem or had a problem I
have been awfully lucky you I feel the
same way blessed super blessed it's nice
to know that and you know that you're
blessed too yeah it's cool it's
grounding I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this